كشفت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا
واوكرانيا تحتفظان بقوه كبيره في منطقه
دونياس شرقي اوكرانيا ولا تغييرات على
الارض هذا واكد الدفاع البريطانيه ان
موسكو تعتبر القتال في
بابليفك مفتاحا للتقدم في كامل دنيا
اسكراجحت عدم قدره روسيا على تحقيق اختراق
في دنيا قريبا من جهه اخرى اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قتل مئات المسلحيه
البولنديين في معارك دونياس وكشفت الدفاع
الروسيه عن تدمير منصات لاطلاق صواريخي
مارس الامريكيه صنع فيزا هيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه اكدت في
تقرير لها ان نصف بدات في روسيا والمناطق
الاوكرانيه التي تحتلها الاستعدادات
للموجات التاليه من تعبئه سريه في صفوف
القوات الروسيه اعتبارا من العاشر من
ديسمبر المقبل